hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in question two
of the first part of the summit
theologian Thomas Aquinas is concerned
with the issue of whether we can
demonstrate God's existence and really
the whole project of doing any sort of
theology or philosophical theology which
is what the the soma in large part is
requires that we we do have a divine
object to talk about at all so if we
can't in some way demonstrate that God
exists well then the entire project
would have a lot of trouble and in
question to article two he is in fact
considering some of the challenges that
are brought to the fore not about
whether God exists or not but about
whether the human rational mind would be
able to in some way demonstrate using
its capacities of reason that God exists
he's still holding out the possibility
of course that you could grasp that God
exists in some other ways but the
question is whether we can use our
Faculty of reason to show that there
must be a gun and he considers three
main challenges the first one I think is
very familiar
to anybody who has engaged in discussion
about the existence of God in the
present because there are still people
today saying things like this and not
only in Christianity which is of course
Thomas Aquinas is religion but in in any
of the other world religions as well
they say you cannot prove that God
exists you have to take that as a matter
of faith or as Thomas is calling it here
an article of faith something that you
believe in and you don't try to prove
because if you did then you'd be in some
way blasphemous or sacrilegious or
usurping some sort of divine capacity
doing something that you shouldn't so it
reads like this that God exists cannot
be made self-evident for that God exists
is an article of faith something a
believer is simply supposed to take on
faith and sense as st. Paul says faith
is concerned with the unseen its
propositions cannot be demonstrated
notice that he isn't saying that faith
is just a feeling or something like that
he's saying faith is a set of
propositions but if you buy into them
because somebody has argued your way to
them then it's not really faith then
it's something like rational knowledge
or natural knowledge is he's going to
call it here so he says it's therefore
impossible to demonstrate that God
exists and there were plenty of people
in Thomas's own time who had very
similar views on this you philosophers
you theologians you need to stop with
all of this you know arguments and
demonstration just believe that God
exists and we're going to come back to
that in in just a moment now another
possibility for attacking this this very
possibility that God's existence can be
demonstrated has to do with somewhat
more technical issues
Thomas says here's something here's an
objection a person could make
demonstration
requires that you use some sort of
definition that is you say what
something is what it's not you know you
have a very clear conception of it and
that functions in argumentation as what
joins things together right so very
often as the middle term in an argument
he he says you know the medium
demonstration is asked quote quid asked
right and so the central link of
demonstration quote could ask the
definition of it what the thing is in
itself a verbal formula or mental
formula for them now do we have the
capacity to say precisely what God is
he says known polska Mascara quid essed
right we cannot know what God is said so
them quit no nest but only what God is
not this is doing what we call negative
theology and he quotes John De masking a
church father in this so if we can't
actually say what God is then we're not
going to be able to have some sort of
rational argument about that even if God
does exist we're not going to be able to
prove it the third thing that he says is
saying well listen even if you do have
some sort of you know capacity to argue
it it's never gonna get off the ground
why not because we think that God is
infinite and anything that we're going
to use to argue God's existence is not
going to be infinite so if God is the
cause and we're looking at effects and
trying to trace our way backwards from
the effects to the cause which is indeed
what Thomas Aquinas his own proofs are
going to do and the next article then
we're going to have a real problem
because the effects themselves are
finite they are limited but we're
talking about something that is infinite
that that surpasses them that transcends
them in ways that perhaps
we can't even conceive of we we not only
can say God is infinite maybe he's
infinitely infinite right and in a way
that we can't even understand the
infinite so what this means is that the
effects are in commensurate they don't
share a common measure with their cause
so he says sense effects in commensurate
with their cause cannot make it evident
it does not seem possible to demonstrate
that God exists so if these objections
were going to hold then it doesn't mean
that we can't say that God exists but if
we do want to say that God exists we
have to take it as a matter of faith and
not screw that faith up by bringing
reason in or argumentation or any sort
of thing along those lines and there are
many people as I pointed out who do view
things that way even in the present now
there's a long-standing tradition within
Christianity and many other religions
but within Christianity specifically
that is actually based in Scripture so
the faith only even scripture only
people have to deal with this that says
no as a matter of fact we can know that
God exists precisely by using our
rational capacities and looking at the
world and here again Thomas Aquinas
cites st. Paul
he says st. Paul tells us that the
hidden things of God can be clearly
understood from the things that he has
made so this is another way of looking
at it if so one must be able to
demonstrate that God exists from the
things that God has made for knowing
whether a thing exists is the first step
towards understanding it and you know
st. Paul also talks about other things
you know the law within the heart of you
know the pagans there's there's a lot of
discussions of this even within
Scripture and then within the tradition
saying that no the human rational mind
can in fact grasp that God exists and
denom
straight it to itself and demonstrate it
to other people so we've got you know
two sides to the the story you could say
Thomas is going to introduce yet a third
side a middle ground and here as so
often he will make a distinction that
helps his position along he says there's
a distinction between different kinds of
demonstrations
there's demonstrating that something is
the case demonstrate Co quia and then
there's demonstration of the Y the probe
their quid for the thing and in in these
cases were we have a different ordering
between the cause and the effect so when
it comes to many things things of the
world we can't in fact have great
demonstrations or arguments however you
want to talk about them where we do in
fact understand the cause and we reason
from the cause to the effects you know
for example we might think of if I shoot
somebody and I strike them in the heart
there's a really great chance that
they're gonna die because of that now
there are exceptions of course people
have been shot in the heart and survived
but let's just say that it was a hundred
percent certain we understand the
ballistics we understand the chemistry
of the gun we understand how all this
sort of thing works together we
understand how the human body can you
know be susceptible to trauma so I say
if I do this this is going to happen we
know the cause we can therefore know the
effect now all of these sort of
objections have shown us that we don't
really know that much about God so we
can't have that sort of demonstration a
demonstration pro pure quid where we go
from the cause and then reason to the
effect but that doesn't preclude us from
going the other way around having a
demonstration quia a demonstration that
so he says he says that this follows the
order in which we know things arguing
from effect to cause for when an effect
is more apparent to
than its cause we come to know the cause
through the effect we know the cause
through what it does now he says that
any effect of a cause does show us one
thing even if we don't understand the
cause very well it shows to us that the
cause exists right because we don't
think that things just happen
willy-nilly with no sort of cause no
sort of explanation even if we don't
understand the explanation for why that
thing or event or happening came to pass
so we look around at the the things of
the world and we look at the world
itself or we might look within it human
nature and we can say those are effects
that we can trace to a cause in some way
so Thomas says this will allow us to
demonstrate that God exists
and he goes back and discusses each of
these objections and what they have to
say in turn the first one he says that
the truths about God which st. Paul says
we can know by our natural powers of
reasoning pair rotc onnum natural hollom
that God exists for example are not
actually among the articles of faith
they're not things that you have to
believe by faith although there's
nothing preventing you from doing that
Thomas says rather they are this
translation has priests opposed to them
but the the Latin is actually prayin
Bala awed articulo they are the
preambles to the Articles and so even if
you think that a lot of things do have
to be known by faith which Thomas does
God's existence is not one of them he
says of course if somebody can't grasp
the demonstration it's fine for them to
believe it by faith but of course
they're not really using their rational
faculties to the highest power and the
fact that they're not able to shouldn't
preclude others from from doing so when
it comes to the second the notion that
we need to be able to say what something
is we need to be able to define it in
order to make an argument that has it as
part of the argument Thomas says we've
got a shortcut around that or a
substitute rather the substitute is he
says when we argue from effect to cause
the effect takes the place of a
definition of the cause in the proof
that the cause exists now it doesn't
work for other things Thomas would say
necessarily but it does show you that
there has to be the cause the cause has
to exist otherwise you don't get the
effect at all I should also mention too
that with the first thing Thomas has
this famous statement where he says that
the you know faith presupposes natural
knowledge just as grace presupposes
nature or the perfect the perfectioning
all right presupposes the perfectible so
all perfections that which they perfect
and that's that's important these these
are not diametrically opposed to each
other and we can say is something
similar here you know the fact that you
can substitute an effect doesn't mean
that you couldn't have definitions later
when you've got a better picture of
things
finally the incommensurability
right is that really such a handicap
Thomas says well effects can give us
comprehensive knowledge of their cause
only when they're commensurate with it
that Daddy grants right so we can't
fully know what God is by looking at the
effects that are just some sort of dim
reflection of that cause however he says
if we're talking about the existence of
the cause that's not really a problem
says God's effects can serve to
demonstrate that God exists even though
they cannot help us to know him
comprehensively in terms of what God
actually is so Thomas argues to bring us
to a close that we can in fact
rationally demonstrate that God exists
and here he's attacking critics we want
to say no no it has to be a matter
faith or our capacities are not up to it
and he does so by making a very
important distinction and the other
really important distinction you could
say he's making here is saying listen
all these other things yes we may not be
able to know fully what God is we may
not be able to know this about God but
God's existence we can at least know
that according to Thomas
you